stern sequence a famous gertingen
mathematician from the 19th century here
is his sequence it can be described in
several ways
it's very important it's one of the
bigger entries in the oeis let me give
you the simplest definition the first
two terms are one and one the next two
terms i copy the one and the one and put
their sum in the middle so the sequence
now begins one one one two one and how
does it continue i copy the previous
line and in between i put the sum one
plus two is three one plus two is three
so we've i've now shown you sort of
pascal triangle it's very like pascal
it's actually like fairy series
f-a-r-e-y if you know it's it's a very
common number theoretic thing
so again to get the next seven terms i
copy the previous line and in between
them i write the sum of the two terms
above it just as you said just like
pascal's triangle now this has a very
nice property if i omit the last one it
has the property that if you look at
ratios of successive terms fractions one
over one one over two two over one one
over three a third in short three over
two that's one and a half
two over three
if we keep doing that we get all the
fractions in their lowest terms it's a
way of enumerating the fractions after a
while we get 7 17 we get 101 over 103
and so on we get 103 over 7. we get all
of them
little ones and big ones and they're
always reduced so that's the sequence
one one two one three two three just
read it like you do with pascal's
triangle if you plot it you get
something that looks pretty nice
like i'm on a
sketching
the facades
of some
cathedrals
this is hofstadter's q sequence and the
interesting thing is that we don't know
if this exists or not it's an open
question just as we don't know if
schrodinger's cat is alive or dead
fibonacci it says that a of n is equal
to a
of n minus 1 plus a of n minus 2 some of
the two previous terms half status
sequences a of n is a of n
minus a of n minus 1
plus a of n minus a of n minus 2.
can you show me an example how that
works well
i guess all right
all right i'll try it begins with two
ones just like the standard naive
fibonacci version i we don't put a zero
in here you go back one step and you go
back two steps right that's how you get
fibonacci if you look at where you are
you go back one step and what back two
steps and add them up this one hof
status q sequence you look at the
previous term but that's how many terms
you have to go back to get the thing
you're adding so what's three so going
back one step gives us a one going back
one step because of that one gives us a
one
one plus one is two so four what's af4
we look at this two so we go back two
steps
two steps we get a one we go two steps
back and we get a one and that says go
back one step and we get a two
one plus two
oh three so that one so so that one told
us go back one step but one step from
our starting point again yeah and
whatever you see under your finger you
add it to the other one let me see if i
can get the next one let me see if i can
get it so for the fifth term yeah
that's a three so go back three steps
yes two three
so a little one okay so then we go back
two numbers which says go back two
numbers to there and what do we see we
see a two so we add that to the other
number so we get a three let me see if i
can get the next one right then all
right so the sixth number yeah six two
three three back one two three so give
us a two two and now three so we've got
three steps one two three a two again
that's a four yeah and once more to make
sure i've got it
so four steps one two three a two two
and three steps
one two three three so that's a five
very good okay that's the sequence wow
now if
we're lucky we can always do that but
suppose
there was a number here which was too
big
and that would say oh you've got to go
all the way back here where it's not
defined if that happens you're dead it
hasn't happened yet but we can't prove
that it never happens pretty obviously
is never going to happen if you look at
the graph this is ten thousand terms so
most of the terms are half of n we'd run
into trouble if we had a term that was
as big as n because this line has slope
a half and even though there are some
little dots trying to escape some little
particles trying to get away they have
to get all the way up
to here or something before they would
kill it and it hasn't happened and it's
not going to happen we've checked
roman pearce
computed 10 to the 10th terms never
never a problem but not proven not
proven here's a picture
of a hundred million terms that i got
from douglas hofstadter who invented the
sequence and you can see beautiful
ribbon-like structure but no proof it
could die at any moment beautiful
you've got another one and it's a
variant slightly different rule but an
even more striking picture look at this
ribbon-like thing this one we know
exists
it's just a beautiful picture a
beautiful graph what's the sequence
that's a graph of it's called a chaotic
cousin it's like the other one but but
different and i'm not going to show you
the equation because it's an equation
and you hate equations
but it's similar
okay okay i mean it looks like that
that's the definition
this is a sequence that was invented by
me secrest it's a very simple rule but a
little subtle you you've got to put down
a non-negative number and always as
small as possible so don't put a zero no
one is going to object to that
now
one and two if you look at them in
binary
one looks like one and two looks like
one zero and you notice
there's no place where they both have a
one
one in binary and two in binary have
disjoint sets of ones they don't overlap
one so there's no constraint as long as
they're an overlap you can have the same
number okay now three ah three one one
in binary and that overlaps both of
these two so i can't put a zero here
because we'd have two numbers that whose
binary representations met that have the
same number all right so it's a one now
four four is pretty good because it's
not over it can overlap with anything
so i can put a zero five one zero one
now i have to be careful i can't put a
zero here
because it would overlap with that and i
can't put a one because three and five
overlap the lower stored a bit so i
can't put a one but i can put a two six
is one one zero what can i put here i
can't put a zero because of the two i
can't put one
i can't put a two because five and six
overlap so i have to put a three and
that's it that's the sequence and what
does it look like it looks like
the alps
on a snowy day right that's that's it
that's a strange one that one yeah
thank you for watching also a very
special thanks to our patreon supporters
just some of them are the names you're
seeing on the screen at the moment and
you can join them by going to
patreon.com
numberphile this was the third and final
in our trilogy of amazing graphs at
least for now until neil shows us some
more if you'd like to watch them all
there are links on the screen and in the
video description and we'll be back
again soon with more number five videos
you're probably wondering what fibonacci
looks like i was yes right from the
start
here it is it's boring this is the first
200 terms and they go along and you know
they get pretty big when we do these
plots in the ois the first plot is 200
terms